this season in the NHL over 34% big chance
here they start with a puck Hond in towards
the net goes to Ryan and Ryan makes the clear
newon Hopkins up to Derek Ryan short handed
scores that one just trickled right through the
wickets on Johanson I'm not sure Ryan even got a
shot yeah there this is a real dagger Victor
hitman's always aggressive in the neutral zone
that means he has to rely on back Checkers and
really good hard work by Ryan and that that's
a miscue by Johansson because stammer gets back
stammer is actually lucky didn't get a penalty
you turn the toll of your blade over like that
you're going to get a hooking call as a rule I
did not see a referee's hand up but that's a moot
point now because the puck did go in that went in
like a curling Rock they've still got plenty of
power play time to work with to try to tie it up
after that misc Nick Paul out in front across
there's the shot from Stan coast and Skinner
got a piece Bard's out the box teams back to
even strength five on five and here they come
with some numbers over the line it's Kan his
shot saved by Johanson on Evander Kane who's
coming off a hattrick now in the middle up the
ice it's aimont aimon shoots Skinner makes the
Stop and a great look for Mikey aimont by COV
McDavid in constant motion bu on a try glove
stopped by yonas Johanson johar yeah you can
see why Hamlin's in the lineup on the fourth
line that's for sure was he moving there's
a shot reaches to net Hamlin with a shot he
scores James Hamlin with his first goal in the
NHL well there is quickness and Tempo to this
game for sure the puck inside the Zone it ends
up in behind the net back up top same kind of
thing the lightning and every team wants to do
and then it's rebound control and he's the third
guy High ready to back check if he has to hlin
gets the scoring chance lightning can't get a
handle on the puck nobody has him directly and
that is a heck of a shot top shell one three in
a row out shooting Tampa Bay 12 to four right
now and they also had to kill off a power play
as this one pops out in front of the net Fogle
with a shot another save and that tip goes wide
and they work the puck back to the line bu
back to McDavid steps in down low oh back
door play to Dy CLE kicked out that left
pad centering pass did not get through the
points and it's knocked out to centerit one
minute remaining here in the first one drops
it off pass across to cout that one directed
scor the CRA Bank Shot he'll take it and it's
21 that causes the problem for the go tenders and
for the defense coov already knows what he wants
to do with the puck when he gets it he has Nick
Paul going to the net now watch Cerro he's got
it he settles it down that's in slow motion and
that's how quick it was but goes off the foot of
echo Here Comes D side into the line to McDavid
and he couldn't turn and shoot following up with
buot that's knocked Away by serf and here come
the liting CRA he's got Point CRA in scores H
in Nikita COV with his second goal of the game
ties it up but it's the quick strike offense and
the speed it's a 2on one eolm actually does a heck
of a job there he's got Braden Point going with
him Echo stops the initial pass across cuz cooch
wants to make the pass lays the shaft to the stick
down that's a beauty but then how about cooch
his sense of the game is so incredible that's
a super slow-mo so he's going to the net but
they get the clear and radish hustles to the
bench now here comes McDavid trying to cut it
or rather Fogle Fogle with a shot and hanging
in there is johans and that gets through that got
through Johansson and the Oilers have retaken the
lead killing the lightning it's the third and
fourth line guys that have continued the attack
here and found ways to put the puck in the net
excellent work there by Fogle driving the net and
then the puck is loose and then see what happens
here when the lightning recover to the paint
Johansson can't find it goes off of chernack now
you're both trying to clear the Puck and that's
just a pile up I think went in off of Ryan this
must have gone in off of Ryan's leg they they've
crashed the net they've gone to the net well the
lightning have done the same mismatch in size he's
a little shorter of statue and you get in the in
the corners with some of those big defens you take
a lot of blows to the head and he did here's cev
up ahead to aimon here comes aimon back to J oh SC
what a shot from tenner J TI
game is I think what caught the goenda
aimont has the Defenders of Edmonton
in trouble Darnell nurs his defenseman in the
middle of the ice watch him afterward he just
stopped he has nobody he's looking around
and it is a beautiful onetime finish from
Jano a little extra space to work with here's
points off the ice with COV COV a shot and it
goes over the shoulder of Skinner Newan Hopkins
puts the puck wide Bard and R shot scores Evan
Bard beats Johansson and it's 43 Edmonton with
a lead again and getting up on the play and Bard
who's been known to score some goals he's got a
terrific relief and that one I think just fooled
Johansson but look at the depth that he get
I don't think it was deflected sometimes you
get out he's in the right place he's out on
the edge of the paint Reef power play now for
the lightning coov swirls back here's headman
edman hangs on kov back and forth across s go
SC and the lightning strike again on the power
play it's ta G what a goal watch this passing
sequence coo off the point point back to co
that across the stam Coast bang bang bang in
the net thank you the go tender doesn't know
who's going to shoot it or when everything
runs through 86 but braen Point does a heck
of a job and it opened the seat up the wall
kipped out by Ryan and down the ice here's B
Boule forc back just bit there by kulak now
the blue line it's Ki KI with gling in front SC
Luke glenning and the lightning have their first
lead of the game quick strike offense good job
by Cole Ki staying on side it he plays it like
a mini two onone because Glen Denny gets inside
position on the attack look at the backhand pass
he hears the yell from Glen Denny and on the
back end key doesn't dust it off he doesn't
try to go to his [Music] for now in comes Nick
Pole to take this draw on his strong side pulls
it back cleanly back to sergachev empty net s
scores from 200 ft empty net [Music] goal win
a face off this was SC by accident see where coov
is this was a set play they knew what they wanted
to do on a clean win get the puck down the ice
because I'm on the go I'm on the Fly is co see
he's behind McDavid behind everybody accidental
Perfection by serach the lightning are going to
open up this three-game Homestead with a guty come
from behind victory over the Edmonton Oilers 64